[Music]
in sexist
justice news that's hard to say
submitted by korean history channel
korea history channel a woman was sent
to jail for secretly taking photos of
nude male model wait what's wrong with
that she didn't have consent to take the
but it's a new male model so in a public
area right
is he in a public area we didn't we
don't know okay maybe it's in his house
is the girl hot i don't have a photo of
her if she's not on they should be
illegal i agree
hot people should never be charged with
a crime that's true what if this guy
doesn't want this girl taking pictures
of her
then that means he's stupid why is he
stupid what if he's gay and not
interested in women
then he should go to jail why for being
gay and not interested in women hello
are you listening what if he's
interested in women and he just respects
his body
yeah you couldn't even hold a straight
face no guys respect their bodies
none all right so this story is a
straight guy at least it's really big in
south korea right now because
the south korean court jailed a woman
for secretly taking photos of this male
nude model
and the reason why it's sparking so much
controversy is because they've been
having a real problem
of spy cam pornography oh and ginger
bongs well they're saying like toilet
stalls and changing rooms
oh public places like they would put
hidden cameras all over the public
toilets or bathrooms
yeah so they're having this like
epidemic right now
and i'd be outraged too i'm like you
better pay me so part of the outrage is
that but
the main thing is the fact that all of
these cases
have been the guys taking photos of
girls and the guys are only getting fine
well i like this because the girls are
fighting back
so now we're recording each other but
the punishment is exactly
the punishment that's really causing
that's the part that's [ __ ] up but i
really like that the girls are fighting
back and recording us now
i genuinely believe that if you record
somebody peeing or pooping or whatever
the hell for sexual gratification
of somebody else's if we went up to them
like if i'm like geo
we just got a great really tasteful
um video of you peeing and we want to
pay you for it
what do you think how much we'll give
you 500 [ __ ] no we'll give you a
thousand bucks [ __ ] no they already got
it though without you
i'm in the middle negotiation tiffany
yeah look she's playing horrible here's
the thing here's the thing
we don't want you to know that we're
taking the video because it takes me out
of it when i see that you're acting yeah
you're gonna we don't want to see your
butthole acting we want to see it in
snapchat get it first
and then ask them and you're the relaxed
state of your face exactly
what i'm saying like it's not vulnerable
it ruins the art of it
i mean don't get me wrong i'll have like
911 ready to go
so that if i don't hear my price this
motherfucker's going to jail for being a
pervert but see because i really do
think that a lot of these cases people
would take money
i really think that because look at all
the [ __ ] that people will do for money
now
like a woman will go on a date with a
guy like as an escort
knowing that it's going to be for sexual
things i think you're talking about like
the bachelor
and bachelor shows well yeah they do
that for me
but you know what i'm saying people are
willing to do all kinds of [ __ ] once
they find out money's involved yeah
hell yeah yeah i think the outrage is
how dare you
not pay me yes i barely have morals once
money is involved
right i think a lot of people do and the
punishment it for the
woman was she got around way more severe
than the guy for the guys
because they know that if a girl does it
they know it's really really really bad
because most girls don't do it [ __ ]
explain your logic guys
are doing it like it's like oh yeah it's
expected right so there's a million guys
doing it
yeah no no no no i'm not saying that
it's not
yeah but then how do you reform a
scumbag by just slapping them on the
wrist
yeah no no you they just got little
fines she got arrested
yeah jailed look i'll tell you i'll
explain why it's okay by the end of this
one your guys's logic we're not scumbags
no so why are we getting punished harder
than a scumbag guys are naturally scummy
seeming right yeah yeah it's okay
boys will be born no no i didn't say
that what are you talking about yeah
let's hear it let's hear it that's why
you can't argue
finish with women yeah yeah they just
try to make it because you always let us
finish our thoughts
they go tips nobody finishes their
thoughts more than you we all know that
finnish no i'm saying i don't think boys
or anything i think it's like
we expect dudes to be scumbags yes and
that's sexist
yes but it's also true yeah yes but they
should just have equal punishment
so i guess let's talk about the the
topic that matter here which is
the punishment part of it yes that's
what we're really talking about
it doesn't matter if we expect guys to
or not like anyone could commit this
crime
right the punishment's so different
that's all you're talking about it's
cause she's
ugly yeah but ugly then of course she's
going to jail i've heard
guys get do you know you've never heard
of the beeping tom [ __ ] this is in korea
we're talking about korean
videos those guys go to jail all the
time but we're talking about a specific
country like no i know but you guys are
saying like you guys always get slapped
on the wrist we're fine we're not saying
always we're saying this story
particularly said
that this has been an epidemic of guys
maybe you weren't listening
of guys doing this in like public place
of cut public restrooms
well i would have heard you if you've
been bart said it or joseph just cut me
off
[ __ ] you that's the true [ __ ] ever
what a [ __ ] dude
slow walked you high fives all around
yeah and
while cutting me off so that was
enjoyable extra enjoyable
he doesn't want to have a good day right
he doesn't want to have a good day
what's a terrible day have you have a
long drive back home but you know what
it was worth it for the best in a
[ __ ] car
for the bet in traffic lunch break we're
going back and getting a ring
that's what we're doing what we're
getting this ring on your bread we're
gonna get his [ __ ]
back on the polishers on his lunchbox
he's right so they're saying that there
has been a surge
of police reports of spy cam crimes
so it went up from 1100
in 2010 to more than 6500 just last year
on a brighter note camera sales are
really high in korea right now
it's a great small business because
they're like it's worth the fine of
possibly getting
caught yeah like they're not gonna go to
jail for doing it
that's so sad and then so they're saying
that out of the 16
201 people arrested between 2012 and
2017 for making illegal recordings
98 of them were men including school
teachers college professors
church pastors and police officers men
jobs out of the 26
000 men
out of the 26 000 victims 84
of them were women so 16 were gay
yeah no if it's 98 women 84
84 were were women so the other 16 were
guys those guys finally guys yeah kids
are animals
yeah and at the dog park spy cams at the
dog park dogs peeing videos
ooh sexy scandalous um well and the guy
that got
that the girl took a picture of was a
nude model whereas these
other victims were just regular people
like not knowing that they were nude
like not knowing that they were on
camera nude yeah so this 25 year old
woman she was sentenced to 10 months in
prison
in order to undergo 40 hours of
counseling on sexual violence
that is wild that is [ __ ] up all these
other guys just getting out
of them that's pretty [ __ ] up though
spy cam same exact way
all they say is that she secretly
photographed him
because i mean there's a lot of
technicalities that we don't know
so for example like what if she broke
into the house in the closet
with the camera that's uh there's
there's like a few counts
versus someone who rigs a spy cam
and they're not invading someone's
privacy physically is it why he
why he was nude modeling i'm not sure
but there's a lot of specifications
especially if they're ugly and they
broke into your house
that is a big one too fine in the broken
journal oh that's completely cool you're
like whoa hey
hi
[Laughter]
outrage over this is not only the the
fact that
the punishment isn't really fair
compared to everyone else that's
gotten caught but the fact that the cops
just jumped on this so fast when there
have been
so many reports from women claiming that
they've been
spy came down they don't do [ __ ] is the
guy famous
that's true is he famous yeah that makes
a big difference the swift hand of
justice works faster for those people
very true whether you're a guy or a girl
if you're famous and no matter what
country you're in
yeah all these protests are pretty much
angry at the police
for being sexist for being hella sexist
yeah
for only responding quickly when it's a
male victim
and for the fact that the woman got a
crazy
punishment yeah when all these other men
just get
fines that makes sense so 98 of the guys
who get caught they get fined
she should have been like don't worry
i'm a man if i was a cop i would be a
real sexist
because if that male model would
complain i'll be like shut up [ __ ]
that's a real sexist that's true
especially if you're a male model yeah
i don't respect you yeah why the [ __ ]
are you complaining a little bit
this is reverse sexist it's sexist
either way yeah but there's traditional
sexism which i'm a firm believer of the
millennial section and then there's a
millennial sex
which right this [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] i
don't like this what does this mean the
cops are gonna take
like this case and go oh my god that
girl harassed you let me serve let me
[ __ ] protect you
yeah that's some [ __ ] dude every time
that i hear that a guy got raped by a
girl
i laugh i laugh i don't know i don't i
can't help it that's the kind of cop i
am yeah i laugh first and then i go okay
what's the laws yeah right
what did he what happened really so what
are these cops then if they're like oh
my god
she harassed you let me come to the
rescue
and then they [ __ ] ignore all the
other girls what kind of cop is that
i don't know if that's sexy i don't
think it's oh my god let me rescue you
it's oh it was a woman who did it let me
make sure she gets punished for it
that's how their
these protests are painting the cops to
be because there are 70
000 people have signed an online
petition accusing the police of sexism
damn those guys are so sexist you're
allowed to be a horny guy but you're not
allowed to be a horny girl
why because you'll go to jail because
she's ugly i mean i encourage you i just
jailed but i've risen
20 girls i do too that's why [ __ ]
shaming is garbage it's so stupid it's a
garbage tear dude
it's girls that [ __ ] shames guys nervous
shame that's not true
shame like crazy guys [ __ ] shame
it's all guys all guys guys it's guys
that can't get laid
i thought it was all girl [ __ ] shame oh
it's a lot of
it's always the nice guys because i want
to be friends with all the [ __ ] it's a
lot me too
i'm like if you're a [ __ ] and i'm like
wear whatever you want please wear
whatever you want
like the santa barbara shooter guy yeah
yeah it's those guys oh
my god please wear whatever you want to
do you know what the problem is because
they are expo women are exposed to those
kind of guys
but if you don't have those kind of guys
as your friends you know
know that they exist but they're
actually they they make the majority of
guys
because they don't get girls yeah so if
you already if you're
if you're already getting in
relationships if you have female friends
you're already not a part of that group
but that's actually like a huge
number of guys but there is a ton of
girl on girl [ __ ] yeah there's this site
called what is it the red red pill site
that
thinks oh god it's funny that women want
to steal your money and that they just
want to [ __ ] you to steal your money
yeah it's called reddit the red pill and
it's all these [ __ ] loser dudes who
who talk about how women like
psychologically
are trying to basically [ __ ] you over at
all times it's amazing it's it's
why i love it we're like we're like
magic to them they can't understand it
as if you guys are all so important that
we that's our focus all our lives
it's incredible dude that's so
narcissistic
just thinking that's what i'm saying but
those those these losers exist
i know well and they watch [ __ ] like the
peacocking stuff in the
pickup videos
[Music]